it for out my career at the fortunate
enough to work with many of the great
international architects
document in their work and op serving
holder designs heavy press it i to
influence the city's in which case zit
en [ __ ] of new city slack dubai door
inch en city  slack room with a something
incredible mixes museum for good food
here new york he fled line
city which means so with your influence at
the development or that it was her
family fascinating is what happens by
architects and planners lief and that
specific project per people like here
in chandigarh india
the city your spider becomes complete lee
designs at the architect le corbusier
well sixty er slater the seat here jumps
opposite at people and very different
ways for whatever perhaps intended for
lack here where you have the people
sitting in the windows of the sm  die roll
talking about the course of several years at in
document in
rem Koolhaas cctv building in beijing and
the
olympiques stadium in the simcity  at the
architecten herzog en de meuron it is
large-scale construction sites in train
shoot to you be makeshift camp
where workers live during the entire
building process is the length of the
construction tix here in the morning and that
formation and savior or and ready
informal  city measurement for quay the
busiest position and plastic
sophisticated searchers the imagination
about the pass seven here said the
following my fascination with the built
environment and for those of you and omi
is since denunciation s led me to
keep alive or a suitcase for you it
sexy 5 this here die and constant lee
under moov least the sand mcm able to
catch most life's most and predictable
moments i here in new york
the day after this and the storm hit the
city
just about 2 years ago he was for the
first time in  caracas venezuela and what
fly-over the cta was the most value
x tent or something too smart reach into every
corner of the city and place for you
70% of the population for life
2 paragraph 3 already about the mountains
door in a conversation' with local
architects urban think and learned
about the torre david
for those five story office building with
its right in the sensor carcass the
building was a construction and until
the collapse of the finish  much an
economy and the des ortes developer in the
early nineties
what I years ago people start moving
into the app and the ndng tower and known
image her home fact in between a free
column of it is a venus tower
so only one little entrance to  the
entire building and the 3000 residence
come in and outs oled single door
together the inhabitants cry out the
public spaces and design team two much
more difficult to place a lesson
and finn is tower in the lobby this
leg to wolsum planted trees
share as well as basketball cord with  one je
look closely jessie bottleneck where
elevator and services for different so
that in the tower people has come up
free full service it solutions in
response to the various nie  ts witcher
journey of living in a fingers tower
with no elevators de towers
Lekker for the 5 storywall cup
design in in very specific ws bij de
scrub of people who haven't het ni
education in architecture design en we
something inhabitant finding their own unique
way  or coming at the power bi can
stretch living city it play switches
alive maico the economic and small
businesses that inventive inhabitants
franssens fine topper when it is in the
most and expect the case is leak the jason
parking garage with your muscles claimed it
is axolute to  shuttle the inhabitants
executor m's in order to shorten de
he got to the apartments
a people for the tower reveals how
residence and figure it out how to create
wals how to make a airflow how to great
and spicy
the circulation en zo water tower and
simply great  in home
this is complete he adapted to
aircondition softe cut with a new
inheritance move into the tower they
already have roef about the so songs
typically  markets space with view cart
a kind of sheets
it slowly van phones materials bols
rise and people creator space of and i
found on checks for materials
it's free mark wotte see the design
decisions dit met king
lek when everything is metal fret
bricks some evidence for cover did
redbrick
with another layer of redbrick patrick
wol
peperzie te meken too small or clean finish
the inhabitants lid rebuilt haptic
handwriting therefore hanson is labor of
love in silence great sense of primary
families
living in dus tower this typically make
the best parents there conditioners and try
to make your space is luke nathan home
or at least interested in a stack
and reach about the tower you come on the
grass also pain or services leaked barber
the small and factories and lack a free
flora's leak little grocery store of
shop and you refined  church and under
service floor chimera
where old-fashioned marbles with which the
parents used the leftover poli's of the
elevators which were  never in the silence of
that antiquity he between oven strange
info seeds that hold fix concrete
teams provider framework for the
inhabitants to greater us in an
organic intuitive re
it response directly to there nothing
let's go to africa when he jerry yatour
community colt makoko a smart
bartender with a 50,000 people lives sister
medical needs spoons league won
because may appear to be
complete ikea take place of your [ __ ]
for me above you seems to be
jacks up or blackwater be a canals
connecting each and every home
[Music]
van de médoc  people bord get tall and
presents
zipper carried out to the various home
cent-shop located in the expensive area
my great uncle de is there is clear that
life sp complete lia aptitude is quite
specific way of living
avon the presents who can quite historical
for lady game  from house to house
selling and i went from to face to face
fruits
behind every window and door frame
lucius need money peering to and
what with ko  kos seems to be packed with
people
in the morning in chili diamant of
chill a bore out of every building
de population growth in nigerian and
specially in die serius lek makoko rp
for reminders
of her parents control links freely arm
in makoko very few assistance  and
infrastructure sexist
elektricity you speak and bottles of water
come naturally image wealth about the area
is a tiger economic model they
are not even pacific way of
living' below there will be such a phishing and
bot measurement a comment professions young
ff set of and spanners
we put business is about the area
lek barbershop city individual stores
movie vierders growers ever finistère
this even a photo studio where you
shoot surf aspiration to live in
a real house or to be associated with
fire where your place seems the hotel in
sweden om this particular exercise  and
came across this life ben west the
tee in the cords measurement outfits
river floating in front of the canals in a
lagoon with a  n fitte taal generator'
for or the community you to enjoy at
night vol de aeria picasso machspeed
black safe for small light help for the
fire
wat origami bread mito makoko was so
perfect for my friend of mine cool
admi
who recently finished building the
straight story  floating coil for the
kids in makoko we
is a tough lot it you excisting
underwater the public space is very
limited
so well the school is finish the newspaper
floor is the play newspaper for the kids
with wine class she mourned platform is to
stretch town square  where the fisherman
mentre nets
and floating shopkeepers doctor boot
another place the leak to share with
you so have loan carlo
third scenes of farmers weekend
migrating of the app have something in the
forties and mattered with the living
at collecting and recycling bes van
gays
from all over cairo for your first
zabbaleen
becomes live in makeshift many songs
value becomes nice edge fine to avoid a
local authorities
with a d  e early life in ethical who
settles and then a mug of tamrac's
coffins from the eastern edge of the city
to day they live in this area approx with
live tits 70.000 people who live in
this community of self image
multi-storey houses where the friend
generations  live in one structure what is
appartments this image for himself
appear to black and the planning of form
ramp something family specializing in a
kind of one form of recycling means that
the ground floor feature art mentis
who takes care of garbage related
activities and the upper floors
dedicated to  living space
en feyenoord incredible to see how the
spanish and papa of car which its
invisible to the people who lived there
black it is ver the sting was my ear
s'posing
wel this car which surf streaming
out he went project is to jan my
hearing and chatting amongst the
stones of car which
what the mole sofas living him anxious
paulsen paus of car which may seem oozing
oil and in have toll sphere
so be  the zeppelin this is between thief
and time takes normal in all this place
is also has 2 tb this dolphin becomes
fascinating is with her family no such
thing is normal and the percent people
are able to adapt or and i end
situation for what the sprite did  common
to come across a small
party or taking place
industries jazz lectrice notch party
in this tradition the bride-to-be display
software in home will be season bring
you your knife point
I gathering seems is of of of assisted
luxe position including new stuff is
display  and all the garbage joostes esp
rotten display all their new home
accessories
looks like coco and the tower the bicycle
so the zeppelin you fight already so a
facilities and thin and typical mee
world there the retail shops the cafes and
restaurants and the community is so
community  of short questions
so or en jozef en de church and long
with this course of religious and king
graphic about the area
and our nice the everyday services
seems the electr  onen creeper shops the
barbers everything
visiting the holmes if the zeppelin is
like they praise or for that antiquity that
sometimes look black any other informal
structure in the city of your step-ins
eggs here with fris also manner of
design decisions and intirio decoration
despite having  limiten texas te spacen
money de holmes en de aeria er design
fresh care in the tail
ever your partner is unique and is in the
video that tells a story je bad something
family circumstances and values
many of these people take their homes en
interiors psv seriously putting  en
lotte forkink erin toe the the tales the
banter pacer our tweet it in the cm and
there were there was the great the info marble
patrons
that the regrets celebrity course on
thames
these apartments on using various
expected be this home which got
my attention on which  the the coin and the
gryce was member freeshipping car under the
front door
when we [ __ ] in the paper this is
fast floor apartment was clean twins
forms into compl  eat animal farm where six
there are seven stocking by piece grazing and
what wise offer living to
with den lek in the apart with a cost
court of discoset elevator are newly married
couple
you must locals the sprites one of the
most and girls the  partners in the area
this pension is that operator with me and is
the al owner of the home so proudly let me
je rand is apartment van floor to
ceiling and free part was decorated
it if it wasn't for this train fifa
milieu en stupid churning order  this
constantly thijssenschool department
eats them first becomes be easy to
forget i'm here standing next to work
out at and reveal extended movie what the
moovly was the most this is a pity
streaming that was in hospital conditions
and will come again open arms in a to
hold it was made with love care en en
richard passion just hit the cost with
two small and there yakult
chelsea after this one can show in a reach
and famous for so of
sluice plateau as much the lift and then
rec  ently and estimate it for 10 million
people in the sizes
underground is dwelling shots your
box kind is architects at
subtraction is your dream sally image
member who in site or so does he want that
quietly you shoot a language you guys
always landscape and hidden behind this
month of  the earth
ardie square rectangular houses with its
7 meters pilots ground
when as a people rider cover
herrhausen of the ground a simply called
leads that there were pure white and apple farmers
who didn't have money to at materials
and this cover old was the most logic
of  form of living van makoko they have
lyrical communities has approach the
tables of planning that are and
management of strong communities en no
we good at w always response pacific lead
to their environment and circumstances
i know it is very people who
live work and play
in the in this particular spaces die
snape oh well so intuitively designed to
make the most of the circumstances in
mustard is places de  government is
completely absent leaving inheritance with
no choice with three projects
because materials and while these
communities ar he is a member it vantage
this purpose
i present samples of brilliant forms of
ingenuity and taste this in die two
deer en billet i to adapt to all
manner of  circumstances potts makes
places lectoren defeat part i leather belt
arcopal is the kind of skeleton
framework for people can have foundation
what i a tap into
nou in match what is already infinium
communities for could create or even
a half he ran artic sound des
solutions would be  after giving the busy
infrastructure that i got up into two
days with large residential development
projects cookie cutting
housing solutions to massive amount of
people
van kleine to brazil these projects
attempt to provide
is many houses es posible met star
complete legionary
and simply  designed his answer to
date in the feature nothing or the people
he must seem to add and twi  tter polls for
my friend of mine and source of
inspiration
see roof on the founder of the wounds
full service foundation this old
dilapidated own your foundland
success the test is play of venus what you
skilling the young jerry and i couldn't
agree with for  more
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]